foreign
hey guys I'm Dave Ramsey host of the
Ramsay show but what a lot of people
don't know is that my story didn't start
and radio it actually started with my
first love real estate you see I grew up
in the real estate business real estate
is how I made my first million dollars
it's how I eventually also went bankrupt
and now after getting back to gods and
Grandma's ways of handling money real
estate is how I continue to build wealth
today I love real estate and what I love
most is using what I've learned to teach
people how to buy and sell houses the
right way because trust me it's way too
easy to do it the wrong way on the
Ramsey Show I get tons of questions from
people struggling with home ownership in
fact almost half the people who call in
have a problem with real estate so I
wanted to do something different for you
guys here we're curating some of the
best real estate questions from the
Ramsay show and releasing a limited
series called real estate the Ramsay way
we want to help you to nav home
ownership in these wild times and what
better place to start than with some
Unforgettable calls from folks on the
verge of making home ownership mistakes
with lots of zeros on the end of them
hey these are some of my favorite
moments from the show and I think you're
going to love them too
we did a
fabulously attended free live stream on
real estate
interest rates had not yet climbed to
where they are now
uh but the uh covid Rush the faltery
pandemic quarantine Rush had eased and
the real estate market was cooling off
because interest rates had ticked up and
people were freaking out acting like the
real estate market was going to crash
and that prices were going to go down
I'll just wait till prices go down and
we were addressing that we had this big
podcast
um you were of course here you were
still in your first few months with us
at that point and it was very successful
we had I think a couple hundred thousand
folks watch that view or watch that live
stream I call it a podcast watch that
live stream and in it we went through
the details of the real estate situation
and explained very carefully how
dramatically the supply of housing is
below the demand
and that any time there is a demand for
anything that is higher than the supply
if you took economics in the seventh
grade they taught you that that means
the prices will go up
when demand exceeds Supply prices will
go up the more demand exceeds Supply the
more prices will go up
as long as that is the perception in the
market then its prices are going to go
up that's what's going to happen and so
we told you house prices are not going
to tank
as a matter of fact they're probably
going to go up in 2023 about seven
percent now at that time we had two
types of house prices floating around we
had the people that had priced their
house way high and unrealistically
hoping to catch a sucker
because there were a bunch of suckers
out there buying property for anything
and everything way above appraisal yes
okay that is not an actual price that's
a sucker yes that's not a price and so
uh now but and then there were people
that had priced their homes at or around
appraisal we were not talking about
sucker prices we were talking about
appraisal prices are not going to come
down we said you can expect to see
people calling prices going down but
really what it is it's the asking price
that's going down because people quit uh
fishing for suckers okay and they get
more realistic and you're going to
expect to see instead of eight minutes
uh time on the market you can expect 80
or 90 days time on the market which has
been typical for the last 50 years in
the real estate market that you mow the
grass you trim the bushes you paint the
kids weird bedroom and you vacuum and
you steam clean and you clean out the
garage and you clean out the closets and
you put fresh light bulbs in you put
your house on the market at a good price
based on what your good competent real
estate agent tells you to put it on at
and it will sell in 80 to 90 days
for the last 50 years
with rare exceptions keyword competent
yeah and then yeah keyword competent and
keyword that you priced it properly
that's right okay so we told you a year
ago that you're not going to see house
prices going to go down we think they're
going to go up around seven percent they
went up 27 the year before but that was
based on the fauci uh pandemic
quarantine so
um
you know the people came out of their
houses after that quarantine like a
Baptist after a casserole and buying
stuff and buying stuff left and right
and so it went crazy and it jammed up
Supply Demand on everything we called it
supply chain supply chain supply chain
and all it was was people are buying
like nuts man and so now now the Wall
Street Journal reporting today
home prices aren't falling anymore after
declining on a year-over-year basis for
five consecutive months which includes
the prices with the suckers that I was
talking about the longest run of
declines in 11 years U.S House Prices
rose in July
the surprisingly quick recovery
which really wasn't a surprise I'm not
surprised I suggest that the residential
real estate downturn is turning out to
be shorter and shallower than many
housing economists expected after
mortgage rates soared last year scarcity
is a big reason
yeah Supply shortage hello yeah High
interest rates have prompted homeowners
to stay put rather than buying new homes
and take on more expensive mortgages
resulting in an unusually low inventory
of homes for sale no honey there was
already a lower inventory than there was
to banned now it's even worse because
demand has even slowed because of
interest rates
prices are generously holding firm
generally holding firm outside of a few
trouble spots the national median
existing home price Rose
1.9 percent in July
it's almost two percent in one month
if you annualize that that's 24.
I don't think we're going to see that
yeah but um even in a market where
demand has been hammered by higher rates
the supply just isn't there says the
chief Economist at KPMG
short of a flood in Supply
it's hard to see these prices coming
down now how would you get a flood in
Supply well you'd have to see a building
boom and we are seeing quite the
opposite the number of spec homes being
built homes that don't already have a
buyer almost zero wow completely dried
up Builders quit doing them
and so there's not there's the opposite
of a flood of Supply there's a flood of
shortages coming so you're going to
continue to see real estate prices climb
Stephanie is with us in Arlington
Virginia hi Stephanie welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hello hi
um so I am a
first-time caller but big fan of the
show I am calling to get some advice on
a first-time homebuyer and I went in uh
the deep end from my first buy I've been
renting ever since I graduated college
and I am at 28 officiated of June and I
ended up going into a large investment
and I'm just kind of looking to get
advice in terms of liquidating my assets
and my savings
um hoping to do this without any of my
parents help but they are offering and
unfortunately crypto is not an option
which I had actually spent some time
learning and investing in
um and thought that would maybe an
option to sell my crypto but sounds like
Freddie Mac and and such have not made
legislation that allows me to to use
that but um I I ended up selling all my
Employee Stock purchase my Employee
Stock which got me about half of the
down payment from my home
um which is only 10
um
of the actual loan and the other half
I'm looking at
um my 401k and the first thing I found
when I looked up
um in terms of getting a 401k loan uh
your show popped up in terms of not
getting ever getting a 401k loan I am
able to take about 60k in cash or the
limit of 50k and a loan but I was
curious to just get your opinion in
terms of the remaining uh 50k that I
would like to liquidate
um
what would you suggest knowing that I
have
um the 401K
and I'm happy to answer anything I got a
little bit lost in the process so you're
buying a home you want to buy a home
if you contracted for the home
contracted I did all the home inspection
and now it's just in terms of uh and you
have you have 10 down from the sale of
Employee Stock
um yeah so in terms of the
um the mortgage so it was I'll just tell
you the numbers it was 760 is what would
be closed on
um and you've already closed on it
oh it's not close sorry that's not the
right question
just stop just a second I don't want to
hear all that that the bottom line is
you have 10 of your down payment you've
not closed yet in the bank from the sale
of Employee Stock correct
yes or no yes or no I need no I am still
working on getting that 10 I want to get
100k okay so how much do you have from
the sale of the employee stock Employee
Stock at 50 55k 55k all right and so you
could do a Fannie Mae loan with five
percent down with that on a 15-year
fixed what is your house what is your
income
um my income is about 130. okay all
right so you can probably pull this off
um
you have no other savings at all other
than 401k and you said you owned some
crypto
yeah and I put down the 14.5 initial
um with just the cash that I had and
that was it
earnest money check
what was that well you put down 14 500
as earnest money on the contract yes yes
all right yeah so 55 and you have no
other money you have zero emergency fund
um I I do have another
um TV Ameritrade stock uh that I could
sell or get what does that work free
cash I could I could pull out 23. it's
55 total but it is I could only access
23 without the double uh it's a Roth our
Ira so I would get double check so yeah
we don't Cash Out Roth IRAs we don't
Cash Out 401ks we're going to borrow one
401K so why is it why is it you're not
cashing out your crypto
um it sounds like in terms of sourcing
um and trusting where that cash comes
from banks are not recognizing it in
terms of the down payment
no but if you sell your crypto and you
don't have the cash sell the crypto
what's it worth
um I have about 30k in crypto so today
um
I believe there was an issue with with
that it needs to be on the books for
about two months
you don't have you have enough down
payment to close on the deal now
you just don't have enough that you want
you can you can do a 95
conventional Fannie Mae loan you have
five percent down
so you can do that but you're wanting to
put 10 down and we're trying to help you
get there plus you don't you have no
money
that you can get to except retirement
accounts and you're going to get penalty
you're gonna get your butt penalized off
okay you're too broke you're too broke
to buy this house way too broke to buy
this house but you've already contracted
for it you shouldn't have bought it
because you've got all your money stuck
okay you gotta because you don't owe me
money you have no money you're broke I
mean all your money's tied up in
retirement accounts and other things so
anyway the the deal is that um
uh uh
yeah I want you to have an emergency
fund in place a rainy day fund and I
don't want you I I I don't care but I'm
saying what I would advise you to do
because if I were in your shoes and woke
up you need to close on this deal you
put down earnest money you made a
promise you've made a pledge called a
contractor by this house and so yeah you
need to cash out your crypto today to be
able to follow through on this and and
whatever and you need to have twenty
thousand dollars cash in the bank after
you close on this house
do not close on this house and put every
dime you have into it because as soon as
you move in crap's going to fall in
you're going to need a new roof and
you're asking for trouble you're asking
for trouble being broken by the house
and so uh it's not a blessing to buy a
house when you're broke you just got the
28 year old fever I gotta have a house
especially a three-quarter of a million
dollar house and you do make 130 Grand
which feels like a lot but you bought a
three-quarter of a million dollar house
with no money yeah so bro your 401k and
your Roth IRA does not count because you
cannot get to that without penalties and
taxes you start cashing this stuff out
you're gonna get hit with a 10 penalty
plus your tax rate so you're going to
get hit with 40 percent Dave I want to
borrow money at 40 interest to buy this
house
I would say no don't do that that
doesn't sound wise and that is exactly
what I'm sure it wouldn't take out a
mortgage for 40 yeah right interest
geez nuts and but I'm keeping my
freaking crypto and I know it's cool to
yeah to sit at some cool hipster bar and
be like Oh I got crypto you're broke
sell it typical crypto investor put
thirty thousand dollars cash under your
pillow for crying out loud yeah yeah you
need you need you need to put 20 000
bucks in the bank and put the other ten
thousand the crypto with the 55 and put
a 65
000 down payment on this house and close
on it yeah and for God's sakes put it on
a 15-year fixed and then get a six-month
emergency fund 20 000 and start building
up your emergency fund there so yeah
I don't even
it's tough man it's
um it's just it's what we talked about
in another segment it's just you get
this picture in your head and you start
getting this fever and all of a sudden
I'm gonna do this and move that and sell
that and hold on to this and all these
competing pictures when you Collide when
you force a deal yeah you always do a
bad deal man and you're forcing this one
for sure
there's a big difference between wanting
to buy or sell a home and actually being
in a good Financial place to do it
that's why our team put together a free
seven question assessment to help you
figure out where you are click the link
in the show notes to get started for
free or go to ramseysolutions.com ready
JC is with us in Fort Worth Hey JC
what's up
what to do about it
um the short story is that since August
we've had
some major home repairs totaling about
um forty thousand dollars that are going
to send us back into Consumer Debt
because we don't have that kind of cash
in the bank
so I guess my question is at what point
do we cut our losses and say goodbye to
this house
okay what kind of home repairs pop up so
suddenly and unexpectedly
right so
um
we had to get our HVAC replaced in
August when we bought the house it was
only two years old which we thought you
know was a dream what did you pay for
that
so the HVAC was about 15. we got the
lowest Seer that we could so you paid
for that that's done
um no we had to finance that
so you had no money when you moved in
the house
well so we moved into the house and
time and you had no money
when you're when your HVAC went out
so
we have we have about 13 000 in the bank
so we could pay for most of it yes but
you didn't
no we did not okay so what is it on you
want me to I see you're trying to decide
whether to keep the house what was the
other thing that went wrong yeah so the
foundation
um
basically with the drought that we had
in Texas this summer the house was
falling apart at the seams major cracks
um so we we actually had gotten a quote
for the foundation a couple years ago
and it was only 4 000 at the time and
then we ended up waiting on it and it
ended up being a lot more so that was 95
and then two what was 95 you've already
done it
yeah so you've already financed that too
yes Oh I thought you told me you were
going had to do these repairs and then
you were going to be in debt so you've
already made all these decisions
well there's one more decision that we
have to make
um and so to validate the warranty for
the the lifetime the um the lifetime
warranty on the foundation we need to
pass a plumbing test and we failed that
and the minimum repairs for that are
thirteen thousand but they're not
entirely sure that that's going to fix
it they the same people that did the
foundation did the plumbing repair
no no it was a different company are
they friends
yes they are they are and I've been
working on
yes they can trench up your entire yard
for less than that that's absolute BS
okay I'd call another company to come
out and start I'm calling BS I'm calling
a lawyer you're going to certify this
dead gum Foundation that you put in for
ten thousand dollars today
period
this idea that I have to get Plumbing
done from your friend before I get your
warranty on work you did BS I'm about to
bust somebody in the chops
okay
I don't think you're gonna do it are you
you're convinced that you're convinced
the whole damn thing's falling down
yeah I am you're right and so yeah if
you want to sell it because you don't
like you're mad at the house
very true yes yeah so what's this piece
of garbage worth
it's probably worth about
it's maybe 300 000. it might be a little
we might have to you know take a little
bit less on it now with what do you owe
on it I'm slowing down about 180. okay
all right
uh I think you're going to sell your
house because I think you hate your
house
yeah but I also think you got to figure
out a way to start living your life
without drama to drama to debt to debt
yeah it's not going because you're
always gonna have drama around the house
and you're gonna have to you're going to
finish you're going to finish borrowing
money on it and you're going to think
differently about the process but I I
don't know about your husband but I do
know about his wife she's tired of this
house she's ready to move
I think my husband is more tired than I
am actually
I mean but now you're gonna get
everything all fixed I'm gonna I'm not
doing the plumbing Bozo that did the
repair on the foundations about to issue
me a warranty or I'm about to come after
him for doing work that he can't
warranty
this is a problem this is a problem and
I smell a red and it stinks
so could be wrong not calling him a
crook just saying sure does look like
one
and so uh that's what I'm doing and then
I'm gonna put the house on the market
and sell the crap out of it and move and
this time by something that and listen
and then and then stop this garbage stop
all this justification and we're stuck
and it's the only thing
we're trapped and all this stuff happens
to us you're gonna have to happen to it
right and it's time that you guys get
control of this stuff and if you buy a
house in the DFW area you're going to
have Foundation challenges you're going
to have air conditioning I mean that
just just got to make peace with that if
you're going to be a homeowner in some
of those areas yeah yeah which means you
can't like you mentioned you can't buy a
house you don't have any money and you
also get a good home inspection before
you buy the house right now and um you
should know with a good home inspection
if you have more than two years of life
left in the HVAC yes um you gotta you
got a 12 year old HVAC
it's come it's coming shortly get ready
you know I mean it's working perfect now
yeah yeah well it won't be for long it's
coming at you I mean you know you got a
four-year-old HVAC you should get more
than two more years out of it hello so
um I mean this is you know it's basic
stuff these things have a life
and a lifespan and the lifespan is only
so long you said it Dave
um and it reminds me
uh
JC you're gonna sell this house you're
gonna buy a new house
and if you don't quickly and
dramatically deal with the drama in your
home
with how you'll handle money how you'll
handle each other how you handle
um YOLO versus we're going to say slow
down and save up for Stuff
you're going to realize in short order
they're going to buy a new house and you
and your husband went with you
and they are going to show up at that
new house there's going to be more we
need this we got to buy this and we
gotta have this and this is going to
break and the whole cycle starts over
again yeah part of me thinks the
spiritual exercise would be to sit there
for a couple three months six months and
make peace with your relationship with
your husband and you all make peace with
decision making and then get into
something else then you're not going to
do that but man there's something about
running from SMS you said it Dave you
got to deal with the drama or it's just
gonna follow you
it's gonna follow you follow you follow
you follow you and this is Thanksgiving
it's probably not a bad idea to sell
your house in the spring rather than at
Christmas
some you know in terms of Market timing
or whatever
um so it might be it's okay yeah go
ahead and bust on the foundation guy get
that certified and then just sit there
enjoy the new property get it you know
start you know spend a month or two
clean it up get ready to sell start
talking about putting it on the market
in March in the meantime in the meantime
get your head around
okay we're gonna control these
controllables these variables coming at
us are not going to control us
and when you live from stress to stress
to crisis to crisis debt to debt
um it's a cycle that you have to
intellectually in an act of your will
break that cycle and it's not easy to do
um I was the same way I mean
uh we're at our house Ramses we are
built-in drama queens oh I mean we can
add drama to anything so it's one of my
spiritual gifts man
a tenth Enneagram for me just for you
just drama queen number 10 on the
internet that's right and so yeah that's
it and uh you know so I understand where
you're doing but one of the things I had
to do is I had to break myself from
feeling like these circumstances were
controlling me
these things coming at me were
controlling me and there's that sense of
power of backing up three steps and go
yeah maybe not
Maybe not maybe we're not using your
buddy to fix it for me Mitchell is with
us in Salt Lake City hi Mitchell how are
you
how's it going guys thanks so much for
having me on sure what's up
so
um my whole life I've been
um pretty financially stable I would
consider myself a Frugal person
um recently my world got turned upside
down
um my wife and I we just had triplets oh
yeah yeah that's usually the reaction I
get from people
um and it's just really just thrown a
wrench in what and how I've been
planning financially so
um a few months ago well November of
last year we got pregnant and right
around that time we had bought in our
first house and it was actually a duplex
and the numbers were so good on the
duplex that we could actually live in
one side completely free the other side
was actually paying for the whole
mortgage and some so we were planning on
living in the duplex
for years a long time not having any
um not having to make any payments we
have debt obviously but we were
comfortable with the debt in that house
and then when we found out we were
having triplets there's just no way we
can fit in there it's it's really it's
really small it's old and we just don't
want to raise our family in there so now
currently we are under contract to to
buy our first house and I'm just
freaking out because I'm not I hate that
and I just feel like I'm making a bad
financial decision that I just wanted to
reach out to you guys and see you know
what what your thoughts are on on what
I'm doing did you sell the duplex
so we haven't sold the duplex
um because now now we have renters on
both sides I'm not currently living with
my parents and they're helping us with
the with the triplets sell the duplex
and
sell the duplex yes
and even so on the cash flow on the
duplexes so right now we're cash flows
if they pay
yeah you're right they don't always pay
you have stress because you're carrying
a bunch of debt that you can't on a
rental property that you can't afford
and if it does if it doesn't work it's
going to go sideways and you're you're
feeling that in your chest
along with the weight of two three
triplets standing on your chest
yeah so so you're right there that
stress does I mean yeah I'm just
stressed all the time now no matter what
this scenario is I'm just stressed out
well it's because you're trying to keep
everything you're trying to keep the
past dream and and Stitch It To The
Future new reality and they don't fit
together
dump the duplex move on with your brand
new awesome life but it's a completely
different life than your little plan
every you haven't got it through your
head yet everything is different now
oh no yeah yes he does I know that
everything's different yeah so how much
is the house payment on the new house
going to be
so the on the new house the payment
would be about 31. 3 100. 3 100 dollars
nice 3 100 3 100 on the new house and
what is the household income take-home
pay
so household income so my wife currently
she's not working she's she's full-time
mom yeah yeah she's for sure working
dude oh I know she worked a lot harder
than I do but I let her know that she's
not working outside the home okay yeah
so what do you make dude
so I'm doing about two to three hundred
thousand a year you're fine sell the
duplex
here's what's going on okay you are
because I'm you that's how I can just
it's easy for me to read this because
I'm I'm like a super planner
I mean I know what I'm going to be doing
in March right now
yeah okay it's ridiculous how how
ridiculously anal I am about this I mean
I just I I love having a plan I I when
we go on vacation I know what we're
going to be doing the whole time on
vacation or it is not relaxing to me
yeah it's not relaxing to me to not know
not knowing is stressful for me okay
you're that guy you're like that right
yeah that's I'm the same person you had
this all dialed in
and the car hit the wall I mean it was
like NASCAR engine up in the stands
doors flew off your plan just
disintegrated
thank goodness it was for a joyful
reason
yeah no they're a blessing but it
completely you're it just you know so
now what you've got to do is you got to
regroup and it's going to take you a
little while to sweep the corners out of
all the wreckage and now build a new
plan with the new situation and you make
a ton of money you're in a great
situation you got three wonderful babies
you got a wonderful wife wanting to take
care of them and now you got a nice
house to stay in instead of that cheap
butt duplex you had stuck your wife in
making 300 Grand
yeah
I haven't even mentioned yet that we
also need to buy a van because they
don't fit in our cars so save up and buy
a little cheap van or pay whatever you
save up whatever you can pay cash for
and then move up a little bit in Van
later and get a little better one later
that's the other thing is people these
these these triplets
or teeny tiny little humans and we feel
like oh I bring it home a 12
um pound human or a 10 pound human or a
six pound human they need their own
bedroom their own furniture set their
own they don't they don't take up a
mushroom they don't yet right they will
but they don't you've got a few years
they need three car seats that's a sedan
that's right you know be uncomfortable
and annoying and all that but you can do
it right yep yep yep yep yep you're
going to be fine Mitchell you're just
going through congratulations you're
shocked yeah you're just going through
shock I mean you're you're a planner and
your plan got destroyed yeah and until
you get your plan rebuilt you're going
to feel the stress and it's going to
take you a little while to get
accustomed to the new Rhythm of Life and
put the plan in place and then you're
going to be there but I mean it's what
you say all the time you got to grieve
the thing that what you thought is going
to be it's not gonna be easy you gotta
grieve that and go I thought this kind
of yes I'm I can't say out loud babies
suck but three of them at one time it's
hard it kind of sucks a little bit you
know and then there's then there's
awesome all the awesomeness but there's
a little bit of you that goes Ah that's
right you know and so that's reality and
that's okay but you're not allowed to
say that out loud I know I'll get
trashed on Twitter just because I said
that so yeah on Twitter every day hey
still let me ask you a mechanics
question
um let's say he was going to profit 100
Grand from the sale of this duplex yep
it'd appreciate that much
would it be best for him to take let's
I'm assuming his house payment is
probably about 500 000 it's gonna be his
mortgage so would it be better for him
to put a hundred thousand dollars down
and drop that Thirty One hundred dollars
a month to twenty eight hundred dollars
a month or to just go ahead and make the
loan and then immediately dump 100 Grand
on top of it because it already I think
he's already got the house okay no no no
it's under contract under contract yeah
if you get the duplex sold in time put
it as additional down payment and have a
smaller payment because that would be
like because that's a I would throw it
all unless you need a little of it to
buy a van but there you go the rest of
it I mean let's be dead he said he was
debt free so what what kind of van are
we going about making 300 Grand I mean
go go get you I like the idea of
collapsing that uh monthly payment as
much as I can yeah yeah well I mean I
always put everything down on the house
I can above the emergency fund and above
in this case a new van and the second
and third baby bed and so whatever it is
you got to buy right and so it's it's
just it's a thing but Mitchell you're
going through
a normal human adjustment to a shock to
your system
and that causes stress right
and if you didn't feel
all of this in the form of stress you
would be psychotic you need to go see a
doctor right yeah and so you know normal
humans when they go through what you
have gone through have ah moment you
know that you know just so the good news
is you're normal right and let's chip
chip away at it right because if you're
a planner you've already started
thinking oh gosh I'm gonna have to hunt
have a hundred thousand dollars a
semester for these three and so don't go
20 years down the road and start
creating catastrophes that you've got to
solve today just start following the
plan chip away and chip away at it I
mean it's your normal Mitchell I mean
this is what you're in you're in this
situation and so you're normal thank
goodness you're okay now you're going to
work through the things that are causing
you anxiety limit them develop a plan
cut loose the old stuff from the old
dream the duplex is gone and we move
forward into the new journey and then
everything will come back down and
you'll get your little planning self
together I know this because I have to
do it all the time this is how I live my
life so I'm right there with you brother
all right guys I hope what you took away
from all this is that home ownership
should be a blessing not a curse and if
you're doing things the right way buying
selling investing in real estate can
become a blessing that will impact your
family for Generations that's called a
legacy and you can start building yours
right now thanks for checking out the
first episode in this limited series and
be sure to share this with a friend who
needs to hear it but stay tuned for the
next episode where we get into home
buying advice you're not going to hear
anywhere else